this is from my mother a special holiday
edition of a made-up game that we like
to call truth or shot-caller how this
works Jordan here has prepared some
invasive personal questions for all of
us
and when he asks us those questions we
have two options we can either answer
truthfully and light them up
yep or with this very similar viewing
device don't perfect but don't present
right now no I can check him no or light
him up in a different way
using the actual dog shot-caller that's
around his neck this is real I believe
it's rated for a dog up to 150 pounds
yes and we might be cranking up the
juice as the game goes along I will say
originally the idea was that they would
either tell the truth or have to shock
themselves but a producers thought it'd
be funny if it was just me
chucking yourself that I would not play
and some of us theorized that you're a
freaky freak who gets off on this oh
that's funny these guys are really funny
I just I've never been invited to your
apartment Jordan I've been to your
apartment twice I think most people that
own pets think that that's inhumane last
time we were trying to get a dog
shot-caller in time for this segment and
I asked my neighbor who has a dog hey do
you happen to have a dog shot-caller I'm
doing this weird thing and he was like
really judgy about no I don't and then
later he was like did you find an
inhumane place to sell you a dog I was
like okay like sure it does relax and
now we're gonna relax with some
electricity Jordan just get away is Nate
first oh yeah Ossining oh I didn't get a
shock you asked that okay who is one
person in your family that you're gonna
see this holiday that you're gonna
pretend to like but actually don't
what's their name and tell them to the
camera that you don't like them Wow
so that's a hard question to answer it's
hard to answer but you know that you're
a nice guy and then you won't shock and
if
answer truthfully I light up the lights
yeah if I don't answer it I shock you
yeah I'm ready with my answer I'm going
to shock it when it lights up red that's
what he gets so you can see when the
light goes off a little bit I Hanna this
is an easy one who is someone that you
get a gift every year but you're like I
really don't want to give him a gift
tell that person hey I really don't want
to give you a gift to camera I do have a
person right hey Hanna no I
okay I can't do it no Ryan your app what
are you up for him who's the biggest
in your family out them on
YouTube I think it's me the truth our
first truth of the day yeah I think it's
me because like you know I probably
could have been real successful in like
at other industries Wow
admirable answer no a little bit of a
late all right that is the end of round
one we had two shots in the truth
everyone's got a shock up there but I'm
going to turn the shock level up by one
we're there oh you know what Jordan yes
you do - yeah yeah I like it
okay let's do it all right Nate this is
easy who do you love more mom or dad
tell the camera what my answer is I'm
gonna shock you yeah
did it work yeah shiny do it again no
Oh baby all right question here we go
similar theme in the cross for you if
you weren't related to your brother
would you date him whoa I mean you said
it right there he's gotta say no what
are you gonna do just for asking it was
a bad question and a weird question
no questions another sibling question
you're going home for the holidays
ranked your siblings in terms of in
terms of how much your parents love them
please assign point values no I see your
thumb my parents love everybody
equally that's a lie have you gone all
the way before it's I don't think we did
I think we won below all the way let's
just do it oh we're going all the way
this is max I mean this won't even kill
150 pounds no I did you fine and you
weigh a hundred fifty pounds he's a good
boy you'll be fine is this the final
round this is the final round
banana make it a good one Jordan I'm
trying to know who in the room and you
must choose someone hmm would you gift
your body for Christmas I mean have sex
with and it's any you know and before
you answer Jordan weighs 150 pounds
[Laughter]
you've tracked me every round consider
that like and this is just like a fun
hypothetical you know never be able to
answer Tyler because if you don't mind
swing over to Tyler
Tyler's a beautiful man please he's one
of the coolest people I've ever met I'd
like to know what's going on underneath
that stylish clothing all right
[Applause]
accidentally texted Ryan that I love him
because I meant to text my wife you know
you're gonna pick Tyler over me sorry
man
I believe the textures I love you so so
so so much so you still have not
experienced the full level shot no not
yo my gosh I'm a little nervous again
I'm Hannah this is a similarly thing
again
what was this like so inappropriate yeah
don't change his pants right on set
right before we started my parents my
pants yeah I know but I was wet
i from the rain your lady pants what
happened that night we're dating
[Applause]
[Music]
what's the question what would you
rather sex role play Santa Claus and
Rudolph or Grinch cuckolding you means
oh you know what you have to be in a
relationship chuckle did describe you in
the room you would want to roleplay with
okay or tell ya I've never made a
question that's more gonna get you
shocked
[Applause]
good how's your throat doing some coffee
Oh some coffee open up that throat bad
dog all right Ryan close us out show me
on the candy cane how long your penis is
Jordan you're asking for it do you need
a second one or like hard or soft hard
some grounds of approval from the behind
the seat I mean I don't want to sound
like a macho dude but I don't think
[Applause]
[Laughter]
let's see it's like I don't know about
that huge my mom watches the show but
also she says she knows yes she saw it
when I was a child but this is from my
mother my dick is huge
yeah right Oh Jordan you're feeling
swell dude you feel thanks man
let us know in the comments a question
that you think we should ask Jordan next
time we play thanks so much for watching
please like comment and subscribe
[Music]
you